people often ask me how can you be so
stupid and still proclaim yourself a
communist what do you mean by this well
I have always to emphasize that first I
am well aware that let's call it like
this the 20th century is over which
means all not only communist solution
but all the big leftist project of the
20th century failed not only the
Stalinist communism although their
exchanger is much more paradoxical most
of the countries were communist are
still in power like China Vietnam their
communist empower appear to be the most
efficient manager of managers of a very
wild wildly productive capitalism not so
ok that one failed I think that also and
here I in a very respectful way disagree
with your by your own in American
neo-keynesian leftists Krugman Stiglitz
and so on I also think the dyskinesia
welfare state model is passe in the
conditions of today's global economy it
no longer works for the welfare state to
work you need a strong nation state
which can impose a certain fiscal
politics and so on and so on when you
have global market measurement it
doesn't work and the third point which
is most problematic for my friends there
is the third leftist vision which is
deep in the heart of all leftists that I
know this idea of critically rejecting
alienated represented democracy and
arguing for local grassroots democracy
where it's not that you just delegates a
delegate to the others your
representatives to act for you but
people immediately engage in locally
managing their affairs and so on I think
this is a nice idea as far as it goes
but it's not the
Oshin it's a very limited one and if I
may be really evil here I frankly I
wouldn't like to live in a stupid
society where I would have to be all the
time engaged in local community Rhian
politics and Karen and so on my idea is
to live in a society where some
invisible alienated machinery takes care
of things that I can do whatever I want
watch movies read and write
philosophical books and so on but so so
I'm well aware that in all its version
radical left projects of the 20th
century came to an end and for one
decade maybe we were all Fukuyama's
for the language program by Fukuyama ism
I mean the idea that basically we found
is not the best formula at least the
least bad formula liberal democratic
capitalism with elements of Revelator
john and so on and even the left played
this game you know we were fighting for
less racism women's rights gay rights
whatever tolerance but basically we
accepted the system I think and even
Fukuyama himself is no longer a Fukuyama
whispers I know that if there is a
lesson of September 11th of other event
is that no we don't have the answer that
not only is Liberal Democratic
capitalism not the universal model and
it's just a time of slow historical
progress for it to be accepted
everywhere but again China and Singapore
and other examples of very successful
economies today demonstrate the dis
let's call it ironically eternal
marriage between democracy and
capitalism it's coming to an end what we
are more and more getting today is a
capitalism which is brutally efficient
but it no longer needs democracy for its
functioning that's my first point my
second point is that
the problems that we are confronting
today we can leave them in different
ways but my point is they are all
problems of Commons for example ecology
it's clearly a problem of Commons nature
our natural environment is our Commons
something which shouldn't be privatized
because it belongs to all of us it's as
it were the background literally the
ground of our being and it's clear for
me that here we need to we need to
reinvent not local democracy but on the
contrary also large-scale solutions the
problem today is not local local
community and democracy the problem
today is how regulates trends worldwide
because even here I almost admire the if
I may use this old-fashioned Marxist
terms the ruling ideology know how in
what a wonderful way they turned ecology
into a weapon against us culpable izing
us turning the car upon us and making us
individually guilty like did you
separate all diet coke cans did you
separate all all all the newspapers and
so on I mean I find it ridiculous how
not only are we making are we made
responsible instead of blaming not some
persons but the system is such how to
reorganize our lives but this solution
also allows us an easy way out then as
if you recycle you buy green products
and so on and you feel well you did your
duty end another example that I used
again and again Starbucks coffee and
others I think it's something very
ingenious that happens there you know
when you enter a starbucks place they
always tell you you know we take care of
nature 5% of our profits go for
guatemalan
rain forest for Somalian children
whatever I think this is ingenious that
when we are consumerist we feel bad oh
my god I'm just the consumer is people
are starving there we are ruined mother
earth but here the message is our coffee
is a little bit more expensive but the
ideological price to do something for
Mother Earth is included into it you
know I even that would be my ideal
Starbucks you know how they print your
bill when you pay cheque and then it
says there that cada Kalidas additional
federal tax or whatever so much no I
would love to have it where they were
put it you know three percent for
helping mother earth included five
percent for Guatemala orphans included
and it makes you feel good and so on so
what I'm saying is that for example this
is one example of endangered Commons
where I'm not under estimating
capitalism here of course man seduced
all capitalist and market tools like
higher taxes for polluters and all that
but you cannot confront in this way real
ecological catastrophes imagine
Fukushima which happened earthquake and
tsunami all that in Japan now it's only
a couple of years ago imagine the same
thing just some it's quite realistic
actors imagining just some two three
times stronger which means that probably
the whole northern third of Japan would
have to be evacuated how to confront
this who will do it and so on and so on
we need a solution here and the problem
is the Commons next point finances
everyone knows that that some type of
regulation is needed otherwise the way
Bank function today it's simply even
from the standpoint of let's call it
naively rational capitalism it no longer
works another thing so
called intellectual property jeremiah
risking pointed out how we are already
almost approaching they're a kind of a
weird communism I don't know how it is
here with you but in my part of Europe
DVDs are disappearing you download
everything it's all its and I think okay
this is one phenomenon but I think that
generally there is something in
so-called
intellectual property knowledge
insurance which is communist in its very
nature in the sense that it resists
being constrained by private property it
tends to circulate freely so again how
to solve this problem I don't think that
capitalism will succeed in privatizing
intellectual property next point
biogenetics are we aware what is
happening today I mean I don't want to
exaggerate and I am NOT a panic monger
I'm not saying tomorrow we will be
robots
I'm just saying that two things are
happening which are more and more
reality a day and this is something so
tremendously important philosophically
direct contact between the inside of our
brain our thoughts and outside like we
all know for example that today's in a
very primitive level but we can directly
wire our brain so that machine can read
it directly and for example Stephen
Hawking no longer would have needed his
finger till now he was functioning with
the finger just moving it a little bit
you think forward your wheelchair moves
forward and so on of course what's the
problem here is that if it goes outside
you just think about it returns it also
goes inside the other way around
so all this prospect of bio-genetically
changing your properties directly wiring
your mind and so on how will this be
used for social control and for example
I've been I visited China five years ago
I got in conversation with some big shot
there from there
academy of biogenetics I mean bio
technical department of the Academy of
Sciences and he gave me the program of
goals of biogenetic in China a kind of a
programmatic text which pretty much
terrified me it opens up the text with
something like the goal of biogenetics
in People's Republic of China is to
regulate the physical and the psychic
welfare of Chinese people my god what
does that mean
now I'm not here a conservative guy who
is in panic
now it's Newfield who knows but we have
to be aware of the problem and it cannot
be decided on the market we need new
forms of global control regulation and
the last thing new forms of apartheid
that's the ultimate irony for me Berlin
Wall fell down now new walls are
emerging all around United states-mexico
West Bank Israel occupied territories
even in south of Spain how to isolate
Europe from Africa and so on and so on
I think the paradox of this global
capitalism is that on the one hand it's
global free flow of capital but the free
movement of people is more and more
controlled and more and more we get new
forms of apartheid full citizens and
those immigrant has excluded and so on
these are all problems we are
confronting today and the big question
is can we cope with these problems
within the liberal democratic capitalist
frame I am a pessimist here I don't see
I'm really attached because I don't see
a clear solution here and certainly not
an idiot who claims or a new Leninist
party or whatever will retinyl regulate
it now that game is over but I claim
just two things a all these problems are
problems of Commons
biogenetics our genetic inheritance is
our humanity's genetic Commons
with abhorrence of apartheid we are
talking simply about Commons as the
common social space and so these are all
problems of Commons and how to confront
them how to deal with them because you
know the paradox here is that on the one
hand we are already getting elements
aspects of communism like again with all
the downloading and so on new forms of
circulation of knowledge even of
commodities which no longer follow the
market models on the other hand I'm well
aware that all this also brings out new
problems which is why as always repeated
I support Julian Assange WikiLeaks but
not in the usual anti-american way I
always emphasize this WikiLeaks should
not be used for cheap anti Americanism
why not because there is a point in
those who say that imagine someone like
Kelsey Manning in China there will not
be a trial he will just disappear
probably together with his entire family
or whatever
so while nonetheless we should also talk
about United States even if the control
is much worse in China Russia and so on
because there is one problem and I can
tell you I was in China in Russia there
people are well aware of the limitation
of their freedom nobody in China has the
illusion that they are actually free you
have local freedoms of choice you know
you can do sexually whatever you want
you can more or less read books that you
want you can find the drop if you find
it of course that you want but the
general social network no democracy
there also with us it's getting worse
networks but it's another point what I
want to say is that the importance of
WikiLeaks for United States is that how
here in the United States we can our
lives can also be controlled and
regulated but without us be
Inc aware of it we still experience
ourselves as fully free and this is for
me the most dangerous and freedom the
unfreedom which is not even aware of
itself as an freedom and freedom it is
experienced as freedom another one here
is we all know what is going on now is
something incredible
Taizo t is a and other negotiations
which are incredibly important
they will regulate market exchange of
data and so on on neoliberal lines so
that they will radically design the
basic coordinates of our economic lives
in one more but the point is we don't
these negotiations are all done in
secret so you see this is for me the
problem of freedom today yes we have
freedom at the level of freedom of
choice you buy this you buy that you
travel here you travel there whatever
but for me freedom has to be more actual
freedom has also be the freedom to
regulate the very basic coordinates of
your life you have a choice between this
and death but how is the entire scenes
which offers you these choices and not
other choices how is it structured at
that level we get more and more secret
agreements we get less and less freedom
so freedom is a big problem today but
it's the struggle sword what we
understand with freedom
you